previously on the walking dead what holy
[ __ ] what's your tip again Vince came on
some people started attacking from the
woods and we got trapped between them in
the fence the two of us should go out
and do some recon and law mount up for
some revenge this camp steep small can't
be their main base that's what I was
thinking take a look around anyway no oh
where did you get this hat a little girl
you stole it from him you son of a [ __ ]
you stole her from me jellyboy tell him
what you got in mind all right how's the
gun bro
cuteness overload look at that carry for
being pregnant and like this all right
should I talk to someone here maybe I
should talk to Anna yeah we met a woman
DNS woman up in the woods she seemed to
know your brother uh yeah he he pray why
that's a little lying when do you think
we might eat when do you think we might
eat hungry yeah don't worry Mama's
cooking up some good grub
I don't trust you it's gonna house the
cows the curl well better now we got
duck on the case doc I thought she
wasn't a vent for cows and horses and
stuff like that all right I guess I'll
talk to the cow I mean absolutely no not
really
can I kick you in the face hmm it smells
funny in here I just farted problem
ducking your what's manure duty and damn
you clammy kids what's up what
what is that [ __ ] duck alright um all
right I guess we go then I don't see
reason to stay
I like the atmosphere with the Thunder
not feels like it's really thunder
outside and oh oh there Joe how does a
woman like yourself from this whole play
no I don't yeah plus I had my boy yes
your balls gross man freaking gross
let's interrupt this [ __ ] what is this
they are hiding something in this pigsty
Sharon our station for the curl pitch by
Holmes will take care of this don't even
worry about it
let's talk to Lily okay we teleport
that's good Lily what's up girl
serious hey so what happened at the camp
did you guys find any more of those guys
that hurt mark
all right I'm believing now Lily Danny
shot someone a woman in the woods she
was talking all crazy and had a crossbow
so Danny killed her
holy [ __ ] was she one of those bandits I
don't know I think she was trying to
tell me something but then yeah went off
I don't like this leave no I don't like
it I still say we should go back to the
Motor Inn where we at least know what to
expect
all right what were you and Kenny
arguing about when I came back from the
camp he's losing it Lee he comes over
and starts talking about searching the
barn and that these people are hiding
something but he's right way I see it we
just need to skip the dinner and get our
food to go but I'm starting to think
your friend over there has another
agenda another one well how about your
dad and Fila but I mean muttering I
don't know if we just stayed where we
were then mark wouldn't have ended up
with an arrow in his shoulder or is dink
it's been three months your dad still
treats me like I'm some kind of [ __ ]
yeah well don't expect that to change
that's just how he is well that's nice
so he isn't as a-- does he treat you
like that too
look my dad can be an ass sometimes I
know that but he's not a bad guy he just
he's got a lot of pain uh I've been
through so much and lost pretty much
everything and it's hardened him you
know
yeah he's bitter and hateful but that's
all just to protect himself and me well
it's not enough tin the world is me that
goes both ways so yeah he's probably
gonna keep treating you like crap but
that's just because he still has one
thing left to gain god damn it don't let
me sympathize with him don't judge me
for sticking by him he's my dad and I
love him god damn you girl I understand
I guess you feel the feeling something
going on here what makes you say that
what exactly hasn't talked about it huh
that's nothing we just talked about it
is she stood we're just getting to me a
little bit come on what you mean
sometimes I feel like people always give
me the creeps if you ask me we should
just get our dinner and leave you know
already [ __ ] said that so yeah get to
nosy these kinds of people are usually
pretty protective of their privacy
how the [ __ ] do you know that this is
stupid sometimes the game just does not
function very well hey what are you
looking at Leigh Leigh what are you
looking at don't touch defense Leigh all
right let's go out I guess I don't see
where else we can go
can we go over here maybe oh good five
fun secrets Oh what is this hey there's
something about this hey what's a hey
yeah that is a lot to handle for these
might work as adequate cover form arrows
if that becomes a problem take a note of
that ly take a big [ __ ] note of badly
alright alright already do do let's talk
to who do cuz I want to poopoo in his
foo food alright what's up what's up man
what's up with you killing that woman
huh alright hello glad I got to use her
today you're [ __ ] sick Manuel here
that is not a girl how do you run this
place with just one cow yeah how do you
do to have more they get hungry too or
sick got your doctor friend here now
though you guys must trade for a lot of
fuel to keep the generators running
right huh huh we'll get hungry and a few
loaves of bread fetch a high price
y'all are luckier on this side of the
deal now well they've isolated you of
the sticks here hard to find you get
many visitors not anymore
bandits of course used to get these
school kids on tours back before the
dead time now the Sun eventually worked
a girl would you put it somewhere to
lack ah it's got a creepy creepy vessel
oh there's a 243 we'll keep you warmer
at night than any lady hi no I'm gonna
go wait for supper there it'll be a good
one
you all right I'll just go over here cuz
he creeped me out
what am I supposed to do I guess I can
talk to these two people that's it after
that I'm done
he's sickos don't you dare make any
demon spawn babies we'll we'll finish
talking later Larry I need to talk to
you that's right later you go off you've
been getting along with
haha he just a big old sweet Hardy he
wants the moat about your Tenet's don't
know if I would have used those words
exactly exactly
Oh George honey this world is bringing
out the worst in people
but if you really look you'll catch a
glimpse of humanity Aaron you've seen
his penis haven't Jam you're disgusting
alright so I was like doing doing it
there that's patient I ever had oh my
boys get so much as a scratch and start
hollering he could definitely teach them
a thing or two about being tough all
right still like to check on it you're
gonna have to trust me on this Lee I've
helped stitch my share of wounds I know
what I'm talking about
alright I want to say ham why are you
out here instead of cooking with ma'am
how come you're out here instead of you
know oh you want to know why I'm not
slaving away in the kitchen is that yes
yes no no I didn't mean for I mean not
oh it's okay darlin dad it's slow
cooking in the oven should be ready
before too long
alright we ran into some trouble out
there
I'll just glad you two weren't hurt
those bandits just don't know when to
quit but my boys they can hold their own
alright so uh why did you make a deal
with those people
we got a thread of humanity lastly we
can do more good without them in our
hair by placating them so that's what we
do think I'll go have a look around
kinda peaceful out here ain't it enjoy
it while you can
you'll probably start hearing those
monsters frying against fence before too
long
alright she creeps the [ __ ] out of me
he's so fat there's nothing wrong with
being fat just kidding it's hurting her
nothing wrong with orange hair just
kidding she's has an accent nothing
wrong with not having an ex I haven't
kinda not really it's a small toolbar
that is a small toolbox I always I
always admire your sense of yep alright
see what we can find here pitted by
Holmes investigator too should be Herbie
let's take it hey hey just gonna borrow
this person yeah
hey guys gonna borrow it if a couple of
tools out of the openness as unsafe as
it gets
we'll be fine here would have been nice
to have one of these back at the motor
area yeah we should take it take all of
it no but they go through a lot of wood
keeping those fences repaired
well you know what I don't know anything
what am i doing that Andy knows how to
fix this if something goes wrong
clueless about this stuff you really
aren't ya
well why did we do what what did we do I
don't even know how to poo what do we do
what do we do I don't even know how to
poo yeah singin and I brought what do we
do what do we do I don't even know how
to frickin poo why don't we do what what
do we do I don't even know what a
freaking pool why don't we do what I
would do I don't even know how to
freaking pool why don't we do what do we
do
I don't even never know what a freaking
boom what are you going leave what are
you laying going Lee are you gonna go
watch frickin play I don't even know how
to be how to pee Lee come on bleep bleep
Lee what am I supposed to do come on
alright fine well go inside talk to more
people I guess cuz ain't nobody
happening
oh that's up okay open the door Oh sup
girls up girls I'm gonna go really I
just had to go back that was it oh no
let's check in here maybe there are
secrets in here secrets
Sherlock barely nothing in here all
right Ian
Sherlock Pitts continues whatever we got
over here
nothing Oh what is this very interesting
looks like a bunch of old dirty clothes
huh smells pretty foul why do they keep
this hair
Sherlock pill strikes again what do we
got over here
Oh time to - huh Lee they're hiding
something behind this door I got a quick
look they got boxes of stuff something
metal and sharp don't get paranoid don't
get Karen job to be paranoid Lee I got
my whole family on this form right now
how about you what about Klem
well I'll protect our took to remove no
matter what I know you will look the guy
with Katya what's his name he locked it
up real tight the second we came in I
definitely heard a noise back there li
ah my point is we gotta know for sure so
go find a head awesome I have the
Knesset thing second I have it to back
me up in case then farmers come running
all right Kenny man dig this through you
smash the lock then what if it turns out
you're wrong you just [ __ ] your chance
to get a good meal and those kids you're
trying to protect
who's your head Kenny use your head can
i professor what'd you have in mind I
have the clip saved what we're dealing
with first I have a conniption
use the clip see look at the screw
connecting we're gonna take the log
apart No hey lis you know how to pick a
lock right yeah why would you say that
because I'm black
is that what tell you razors oh you are
not soon oh no you get out oh no her
crazy [ __ ] just comes out of my mouth
sorry why did it why what why those
screws instead of break in the padlock
we can just take off the assembly have a
peek inside and then replace it all
again like nothing ever had sounds like
you got a play hang around hang around
and keep an eye on that guy with the cow
Andy [ __ ] off I thought that was Danny
whatever can I help you boys find
something I don't worry about it
Danny we got this under control uh
triple dot that's fine I triple doctor
you [ __ ] no we're fine just
looking around
nice going lis I'm Kevin hey do me a
favor don't [ __ ] around with this door
okay just you know mama gets nervous
Andrew I need your help again
no perfect time to strike what is behind
this door huh well we're just going to
find out
hey guys seriously don't [ __ ] around
with that come on enough already
distract Andy to get out I thought he
went out how about we tell Andy that
Larry is [ __ ] with her how about that
Monday
hey there Andy yeah so uh Danny
mentioned you needed something he
mentioned he needed something did you
say what [ __ ] I can't remember now sorry
huh all right all right be right back
doc ha ha ha ha ha
a Baudette ha ha ha stupid [ __ ] all
right Kenny now's our chance
Kenny finally multi talked up something
I think could help with the lock all
right
good here
all right let's do it Kenny let's see
what's beyond this let's do this
that's the we're sure got that son of a
[ __ ] false alarm
oh [ __ ] we gotta try harder than that
Kenny what do I do
Kenny hey there Andy yeah alright ah so
where do you keep the rest of the tools
but if you need something just tell me
what it is and I can get it for you yeah
not that important why do you lock that
door this you can't afford to lose our
[ __ ] to the people in the woods they
come down here every once in a while
raid our stuff even with the fence
alrighty then alright and then I guess
we got to find something to distract
them with
but how in the heavens are we going to
do that totes my god Scouts
maybe we can [ __ ] the generator up or
something
yeah yeah that's a good distraction do
that
let's put it to off po s words haha
click it my man worse word yes I know
what [ __ ]
hey wait who's Andy alright and now [ __ ]
with it cut it off yeah damn it
think it's moving fast Wow Wow damn it
think it's moving fast looks like that
Bell struggling here
what'd you call me whatchamacallit
well what am I supposed to do it oh I
have to turn it off power switch [ __ ]
click on Italy now we cut it off hey
don't be behind me that should do it
oh you're not gonna fix anything [ __ ]
Danny where do you find this piece [ __ ]
ha ha ha [ __ ] pad rule bill damn
it'll take forever
yep that's gonna take forever ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha
Jaden spitty strikes again I don't
suspect a thing
look at it don't suspect us now we're
gonna find out what's behind this door
and the next episode I'm just kidding
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna do that all
right
all right Kenny Mouse our chat and
you're ready for this Kenny my man I
really got a piece of this better be
good all right here we go
mom dad dinnertime it's dinnertime yeah
you got anything honey let's get that
dad dad come on shut your mouth
Kenny come along honey Kenny come on
don't make the children wait
shut up excuse for you get that thing
off all right Thank You Kenny my man
Kenny you rule Kenny you the main remain
Kenny you're the main you the main can
you the main click ro glad to click all
of them really fine I'll do it
Oh No thus why did they make me do this
dress hey grandpa
aah Quadra oh lucky where I got Amba
there you go there we go
seem solid I got a nice rabbit
what is it lay yeah yeah huh
what in the hell didn't you hear the
bell
Oh dinnertime and this F is out here
alright like village enjoyed the sky
coverage PLC makes it so dope I have on
it that's my approach the best tip I can
give you as a youtuber I think I stole
it from Freddie Wong but make videos
because you like making videos the rest
will come by itself and if you don't
make videos because you are enjoying it
then you're just gonna stop making
videos anyway